To drill down for a minute into this question of data transport ability.
This is sometimes called serialization in Java, or marshaling, or even pickling.
Some of the differences that might arrive have to do with bit order. Yes,
some machines order the bits from high order to low order in different orders.
Byte orders within a word. Different character sets that are used. Alignment,
that is, whether, particular pieces of data are aligned on word boundaries or
byte boundaries. Okay? And then the whole question of word length. Now we have,
of course, 64-bit, words, but other machines are only 32-bits. And,
of course there are, uses, of, data storage in which we wish to use
less than a full word. Even after these, differences are resolved there's still
the question of how the various pieces of some complex data are,
are, are organized. Okay? Must they be kept in a certain order? Can they be,
can they be shuffled around in order to compact them? These days,
many, approaches to data representation include self-definition. That is,
not only are you communicating with data, but
you're communicating at a description of the data. That,
can then be decoded at the other end. Fortunately, various, standards have,
arisen to address these kinds of questions. Internet standard x680 is one, and
then on the commercial side Google has developed the idea of protocol buffers.
Which are descriptions of data.
Which then can be incorporated into your applications for
communication among the pieces and interpretation at either end by an API.